vous avez entendu la fin de télématin
axel de tarlé qui disait qu'un salarié
sur quatre en télétravail risque en
pyjama toute la journée ben a fait un
bel hommage
à cette petite statistique avec boîte
petite robe de chambre du matin celle
des arrivages à j'aime bien les
téléspectateurs apprécieront faisait
comme mon père était bon qu'on manquait
pas a commenté sur tweets mais vous
faites comme vous voulez mais moi ça
m'attriste après vous mettez le
commander la boe bon là c'est ici que
j'entretiens montpetit gazon
effectivement
parce que ça c'est que la 3g mais
attendez
c'est vraiment la plus pour le magasin
je la connaissais alors apparemment
celle enseigne donc c'est ici que
j'entretiens mon petit gars zowie ours
et plus ou moins de bon vous savez ce
que vous en pensez mais moyens vous le
connaissez ça a été votre professeur de
philosophie en effet ce terme
professeurs seraient aussi au lycée à
courbevoie en fait elle était très bon
élève je suis sûr elle est une élève
délicieuse et studieuse et évidemment
qu'ils avaient envie d'apprendre une
boule de poils pour cacher une autre ah
oui avec le chat entre les jambes
écoutez il faut leur reconnaître une
chose elles ont beaucoup d'humour sont
bons ils sont très bons aucune idée on
dirait un décodeur de télé allez on vous
aide c'est une boîte noire
une boîte noire mais la boîte noire pour
les avions non plus seulement à partir
d'aujourd'hui tous les nouveaux modèles
de voitures homologuées devront en être
équipées
occasion
il ya une partie de moi qui ai envie de
lui dire stop là on y va on reprend la
course moi j'ai une course à gagner il
faut que j'y aille sauf qu'en fait il
est tellement gentil le fait qu'il fasse
un détour chez lui c'est pas simplement
pour mettre un tee shirts et qui va
passer descendants qui vient mettre de
l'essence
je peux rien lui dire quoi placé sous le
capot la boîte noire enregistrera votre
vitesse les phases d'accélération de
freinage
le port de la ceinture ou l' usage des
phares et des clignotants ces données
seront effacés toutes les deux minutes
il a fallu se creuser la tête pour
voyager tu te fais prendre un train à 14
heures qu'a été annulée donc géré
changer à partir de là pour en trouver
un autre à 8h30 ce matin qui a été
supprimée donc hier soir il a plu je
retrouve un billet de train pour partir
à 10h15 ce matin un vrai casse tête
[Musique]
on se rend très vite compte qu'avec nos
poids respectif en fait ça va être
compliqué et comme un bonheur n'arrive
jamais seul je me permets de vous offrir
aussi ce coup trop de l'amitié ce
couteau opinel carey allait vivre de
nouvelles aventures et qu'un marin ne
prend jamais la mer sans emporter avec
lui ça et son couteau c'est le tlm
turquie teb ça va aller ça valait bouge
pas ce qui est bien c'est que tout et on
a vu qu'on était un petit peu en
difficulté est là au cas les nerfs
revanche si on est resté x-men très peu
de mots justes que des mots
d'encouragement mais aucun ossement de
voix
à l'examen ravaux que j'avale ici xav
bravo bravo c'est génial clavier c'est
génial à xavier ravaux xav voici bob un
pigeon un peu trop voyageurs l'oiseau
habitué des compétitions et des courses
devait se rendre en angleterre à 600
kilomètres de chez lui à guernesey mais
le volatile s'est trompé de route et se
retrouver aux etats-unis à plus de 6000
kilomètres de là c'est un habitant de
l'alabama qui l'a recueillie alors je
suis vraiment heureux de consacrer ma
modeste chronique à cette activité parce
que personnellement j'adore et papa
uniquement parce que je suis un viandard
qui adore les merguez des brochettes de
boeuf les côtes de boeuf et et tout ça
mais aussi parce que j'adore allumer le
barbecue bah ouais parce que quand on
aime le barbecue on aime bien faire son
petit truc le personnel a pu rassurer
son propriétaire inquiet après 20 jours
sans nouvelles de son animal selon lui
son pigeon s'est perdu en chemin et a
probablement fait la traversée de
l'atlantique sur un cargo aujourd'hui
bob va bien reste à organiser son voyage
retour un artiste agriculteurs à a
trouvé un moyen original de lancer un
appel au secours regarder grâce à son
tracteur en fait il dessine des messages
dans les chambres a depuis les airs on
peut lire water save water même
traduction économiser l'eau l'italie qui
suivit des vagues de chaleur et un
manque crucial dont
c'est une idée camping très décrié en
ligne il faut dire qu'utiliser des
centaines de mètres de rouleaux de film
plastique pour construire une tente en
forêt a de quoi surprendre et agacé
beaucoup d'internautes conseille
d'acheter une plante réutilisables à la
place ce sera moins cher et surtout
beaucoup plus écologique
un message à faire passer à ceux et
celles qu'ils sont nombreux qui ont déjà
monté des abris de ce genre hier le
ministre de la santé françois braun a
demandé aux français d'être responsable
et de remettre le masque dans tous les
lieux d'affluence le maire de nice
christian estrosi a décidé ce matin de
ne rendre obligatoire dans tous les
transports de la ville dès lundi et nous
on se quitte avec la photo du jour
garder le coup d'envoi des célèbres
festivités de san san firmin à pampelune
en espagne et il ya déjà beaucoup de
monde une tradition qui revient après
deux années blanches et des festivités
qui sont évidemment connu dans le monde
entier